So how far are
you coming from?
I come from South.
OK.
All the way South?
Yeah.
Coming in and going to--
heading North.
Heading North, yeah.
OK.
Yeah, we are rounding
up these horses.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
My horses had strayed from
the swampy Sean Roundup.
The one I'm riding
has a name, Buckshot.
[music playing]
All these horses
belong to the community
where these guys are from.
Now normally, these
horses are running wild,
so they had to round them up.
The horses are being taken to a
ranch a few days ride from here
to sit out the worst
of the rainy season.
[music playing]
Hut.
As a thank you for
finding their horses,
the cowboys invite me for food.
I join a rider called Chardo
to help him set up camp.
Whoa.
What is that?
Anaconda.
Right there.
He's definitely
freaked out horses.
[music playing]
This monster snake is
right on the trail.
We got to get it
safely out of the way.
That's a big snake.
Whoa.
[music playing]
Here.
You can see those.
Just rows and rows of
really sharp teeth.
Those are jaws
that mean business.
The snake stays hidden
in murky water like this.
You can see how that camouflage
once it's submerges itself
just a little bit
below the water,
it just simply disappears.
When they're active
like this one,
it usually means they're
looking for prey.
It's waiting for anything
that can fit into the jaws
of the snake that's fair game.
And these snakes can
easily eat an animal size
of a pig wandering
through these waters,
getting a drink of
water, and boom.
And it would constrict
that prey to death
so it couldn't breathe, stops
the blood flow of that animal,
the animal eventually
passes out.
And then the animal is safe
to eat, it'll find its head,
and then eat whatever
it caught head first.
[music playing]